once I reach a point in my career I was
tired of trying to be something I wasn't
being you will upset some people but
it's essential to your success that you
are okay with that I'm not doing
anything for you know any other reason
other than it's just me rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
just be you over to you Dwayne Johnson
also if you want to know what Dwayne
Johnson and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confident series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below my call time is at
7 then you back your clock up for hours
and then that's when I get up at this
point in your career when most people
would be like hey get those cameras away
I don't talk to anybody every single day
you talking to the people why is it it's
the most important relationship I have
is with the people so I reached a point
in my career I was tired of trying to be
something I wasn't Wow so I was told at
that time listen you can't talk about
wrestling you can't go by the rock you
can't be as big again yeah it was a lot
of things like that so finally I reached
a point where I said all right two
things have to happen I'm gonna surround
myself with a different group of people
different management and and then I'm
gonna make sure that that I just got to
be me right me and if you want to call
me Rocky call me rock all right I'm
gonna get a no cuz I was like I should
have come no no it's always rock being
you will upset some people but it's
essential to your success that you are
okay with that you are not willing to
actually be yourself and actually bring
yourself to your business because you
are afraid of upsetting somebody in your
life maybe it's your mom who wants
join the family business maybe it's your
dad who wants you to have a successful
career and go be an accountant maybe
it's your friends who think if you move
away and you become a success and you
will be a sellout with success comes a
lot of people that will love you and
some people that will hate you and if
you are not willing to accept that not
everyone will love you then you will
never do anything special with your
business so I recently came back from LA
I was doing a speech at a video
marketing event and at the end of the
evenings I was always invited to go out
to the VIP dinners and the go-karting
all the fun activities and I didn't
really want to do that not because I'm
better than anybody else
just because I'm introverted and I
didn't like going to big parties and I
don't like being away from the hotel for
too long and I just don't like big group
events and so I politely said no and I
went to dinner by myself and grabbed a
Subway sandwich and came back to the
hotel and ate in the lobby and engaged
with the people who are there at the
event one on one until 2:30 3 o'clock
every single morning and and it was the
best an earlier version of me would have
been sad about that would have made
myself go to those events would have not
liked myself for going to those events
because I wasn't willing to accept that
I'm an introvert and anytime for myself
and I don't like doing big group parties
and events and when I fully accepted
that and started living that that's when
more great things started actually
happening to me that's when that event
in LA became one of the the greatest
events of this year for me because of
all the people I was able to help where
if I went to the big group events and
sat in the corner and was upset or
depressed it wouldn't have really led to
a lot of success for me or the people
around me now not everybody may have
liked that maybe some people expected me
to go a lot of people probably expected
me to go all the other speakers were
going maybe some people would be upset
about that and maybe they call me out or
they talk negatively about me I don't
think that's the majority of people and
maybe that didn't happen with anybody
but it wouldn't surprise me if some
people were upset or hurt that I didn't
go to the events and it wasn't my
intention to hurt people it's just me
being me and by me being me a lot of
people benefit from that and some people
will not benefit and not be happy about
it but if I'm unwilling to go off and be
me and do what
I do and do what I love because I'm
worried about two or three people's
opinions and then being hurt or upset by
it or not understanding it then it means
that I'm not able to go off and impact
hundreds and thousands and tens of
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people so you have to do you otherwise
you'll never have the impact you want to
have and you'll never be happy okay so
the next bit of advice becomes how do
you do it because the most common piece
of advice for a lot of people is just be
you but how do I do that how do I figure
out what that is how do I get the
courage and strength to be able to do it
I'm gonna give you three tips that will
help number one is figure out what your
one word is figure out what your one
word is your one word is your most
important core value and this becomes
the rock that you stand on when somebody
wants you to do something that you don't
believe in when somebody has an opinion
that you don't quite agree with if you
don't know what you staying for then
it's easy to be swayed by other people's
thoughts and opinions but when you are
rock solid when you know this is who I
am this is what I'm all about this is my
most important core value then it's
harder for people to push you off of it
alright I'm all about belief if you
don't love belief amazing no matter how
much you hate believe you're not gonna
push me off that I rock as I believe and
what I believe I believe and believe and
you're not gonna push me from that but
if it's something else that I'm not a
certain in or if I didn't have believe
is my one word and didn't know what it
was then it'd be easy for me to doubt
myself it'd be easy for me to think huh
maybe this person's right and if you're
constantly living your life based off of
other people's opinions judgements
values then you're never actually doing
your thing and you feel pulled in a
million different directions and so step
number one for me is self-awareness and
figuring out what is your single most
important one word core value step two
has identified the biggest change what
is the single biggest change that you
need to make between being the person
who you pretend to be or the person who
you maybe like the show that you are
versus the person that you actually are
what is that single biggest change and
so for me was exposing that I'm an
introvert and saying no to going to
those events and saying no to the
dinners and the gold cards and then even
taking up my phone and making a video on
the streets of LA saying guys I'm having
an introvert moment and I just feel like
being by myself for now in that video
that I posted on Instagram and also on
YouTube ended up being one of the best
performing videos on my Instagram
channel the people really resonated with
it and said thank you
for giving me the permission to be
introverted as well I really resonate
with what you're saying and so step two
is to figure out what is that single
biggest change of the person you know
you are but you're not expressing yet
you have to figure that out and then
step three is to ignore the little man
that you have to go in on that thing if
you know if you know in your heart that
there's something inside you that should
be expressed but you're afraid to do it
because of somebody else's opinion I
call that the little man the little man
is a person that tells you all the
reasons why you're not gonna win all the
reasons why your ideas suck and why you
suck and why it's never gonna happen for
you that's a little man the haters and
naysayers the non-believers those people
in your life you have to be able to
ignore them you have to be able to do
the thing some of the strength to do the
thing that you're afraid to do to put
yourself out there to be the introvert
or to be that whatever it is for you and
embrace it that's who you are
you found your one word you figured out
what the biggest thing is that you need
to change and then you need to go off
and express it and ignore what the
people around you are saying because net
most of the people will love you most of
the people will embrace you and you'll
be a vocal minority people who won't
like you who will say that that's stupid
who won't believe in you who say you're
never gonna make it who say that's a
really stupid idea they just won't buy
into what you're doing and that's okay
and I know there's a tendency to if you
got a hundred comments on a video and 99
of them are positive and one is negative
you only pay attention to that one
person that one little man that one
person who says that you suck I know
that's where we want to go but a little
shift to say you know what there's 99
people who love what I'm doing I'm
awesome so number one figure out what
your wonder it is to figure out what the
biggest change is that you need to make
and Express and in three go for it and
ignore the little man now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know whose
opinion is preventing you from being who
you are let me know put in the comments
below
I was getting interviewed the other day
in some interview and the guy said
something about like um you know it's
impressive how quickly you've built your
brand right and I looked at him and I
said I'm not a brand I'm a person I'm a
person what I'm doing is not what I'm
doing so that I can leverage people what
I do is just me and I'm just a person so
if you asked me if I would wear a
rainbow t-shirt I wouldn't know I've
asked you to wear lots of stuff would
you have if and if you asked me but but
that's not because of I'm trying to be
something it's because that's who I am
right and I have been I had one of my
bros who I hadn't seen in a while and he
we met at a little place would go to in
San Diego and I hadn't seen him in a
year and a half and he comes walking in
and he sees me and I'm wearing the same
thing that I always wear pair of jeans a
victory black t-shirt and he walks in
and he see in a fight it was a winter
time and I was wearing a flannel like a
whatever like oh we can do England yeah
like a New England but like cheap
whatever flannel with the quilt inside
of it yeah
and um he sees me and like when he sees
me and this is kind of you know after
the books and the podcast and he's
another seal so he suspect and he sees
me and I see his face and his face like
gets a happy when he sees me and he and
he comes over and like does like a bro
hug and he says probably you're exactly
the same and I was like yeah man and he
goes I knew it and like that to me was
the best compliment I'll ever get is
like okay no matter what happens I'm not
a brand I'm not doing anything
for
you know any other reason other than
it's just me and that's just just what
I'm doing and if people are cool with it
man that's awesome
you are an ambassador and for this
campaign when we talk about perfect
never and what it exemplifies why were
you so drawn to it and the fact that you
were willing to kind of be the face of
what this campaign is well it kind of
seems I guess like strange in a weird
way that like a model who's supposed to
be perfect is the face of a perfect
never campaign bike I guess that was the
point to me is that people were like why
her and that's the point is that
everyone always calls me perfect and I'm
just not letting like everyone else you
know there's things that people think I
am and and that there's parts of my
career obviously that are very visual
based but there's a lot more to me and
and when I connect with people on a real
level you know with all of these girls
who are friends to me or have been in my
life in some way we connect on something
very different to what the world judges
me on you know what I mean so that's
what's important to me is that I wanted
to do something that I feel like I at
the end of the day don't feel suffocated
by not being allowed to be myself in
some way ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would become
like a little beacon if you want some
intense Dwayne Johnson motivation check
out the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I did a lot of my
growing up in Hawaii and all my ears
as family I was evicted out of Hawaii we
were picked it out of our little
efficiency